>> Dana: CRITICS ACCUSING
KAMALA HARRIS OF GOING AWOL ON
THE ISSUE OF THE LARGEST MIGRANT
CARAVAN EVER.
NEARLY 10,000 MIGRANTS GATHERING
IN MEXICO EXPECTING TO MAKE THE
DANGERS THE TRACK.
ACCORDING TO SOME MIGRANTS THE
POLICIES OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OFFER A VERY BIG
INCENTIVE TO MAKE THE JOURNEY.
THIS BECOME PROMISED THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY.
HAVE US HAVING.
NOW WE NEED HIM TO KEEP HIS
PROMISE.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS FRIENDLIER TO
MIGRANTS THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS?
>> I THINK BIDEN IS FRIENDLY.
>> Dana: JESSE, KAMALA HARRIS
IS GOING TO DO AN EVENT.
PRETTY MUCH NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE ACTUAL VIOLENCE PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: SHE SHOWERED THESE
CORRUPT CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES WITH CASH THAN THEY
STOLE THE MONEY AND KEPT SENDING
THEM TO CARAVANS NORTH.
TYPICAL LIBERALISM.
THROW MONEY AT A PROBLEM IT
KEEPS GETTING WORSE.
DIDN'T ONE OF OUR CORRESPONDENCE
INTERVIEW ONE OF THE PRESIDENT
IN ONE OF THE CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES THAT A GUY SAYS YEAH,
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM KAMALA IN
ABOUT A YEAR.
SHE DIDN'T EVEN CALL THE GUY.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS.
SHE HAS GOT TO BE SO LAZY.
DEEP, BEEP.
THIS IS VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS PURELY SENT YOU A
LOT OF DINERO, HOW ABOUT YOU
STOP THE CARAVAN?
MOVE FROM CHARACTERISTIC.
STOP THE CARAVAN, STOP STEALING
THE CASH.
MAYBE THERE'LL BE SOME
CONSEQUENCES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES WILL BE.
THAT'S NOT MY JOB.
SEND THE CIA.
THEY WILL KNOW WHAT TO DO.
YOU THINK LETTING A MILLION
ILLEGALS INTO THE COUNTRY HELPS
THE INFLATION PROBLEM?
IT EXPLODES INFLATION.
IT DESTROYS THE DOLLAR.
ANYBODY WITH A BRAIN SEES THAT.
HOW MUCH -- HOW COME SHE DOESN'T
SEE THAT SHE IS MAKING INFLATION
WORSE?
>> Judge Jeanine: WAS IN AT
253,001 MONTH?
TALKING TO .5 MILLION.
HERE'S THE THING.
YOU WOULD THINK THE WOMAN IS A
PROSECUTOR, THAT SHE'D
UNDERSTAND OUR MONEY IS GOING TO
CORRUPT GOVERNMENTS IN
CENTRAL AMERICA AND SHE HAS BEEN
TASKED WITH THE IDEA OF FINDING
OUT WHAT THE ROOT CAUSES OF
IMMIGRATION ARE.
SHE WOULD DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT IS COMMON SENSE.
THIS WOMAN IS LAZY.
SHE IS A LAZY HUMAN BEING.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO FOCUS HER
MESSAGE.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO GET OUT
THERE.
SHE HAS BEEN IN LATIN AMERICA
FOR THREE FULL DAYS.
MEANWHILE JOE BIDEN WAS THERE A
FEW WEEKS AGO SIX DAYS IN A ROW
AND NOW THEY HAVE AN END GAME.
THEY WANT TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE
TO THE SUMMIT OF AMERICAS.
SHE IS CALLING EVERYBODY AND
BEGGING THEM TO SHOW UP AND THEY
WON'T SHOW.
THE WOMAN, SHE IS MORE THAN A
LAUGHINGSTOCK.
SHE IS MORE THAN SOMEONE WHO IS
INEPT.
SHE IS LAZY.
HE DOESN'T DESERVE A JOB.
SHE SHOULD JUST RESIGN.
SHE'S NOT DOING ANYTHING.
>> Dana: SHE'S NOT GOING TO
RESIGN.
I THINK SHE THINKS SHE'S GOING
TO BE THE DOMINE IN 2024.
>> Greg: DOING WHAT SHE IS
SUPPOSED TO DO WHICH IS NOTHING.
AMERICA SAYS BUILD A WALL AND
SHE GOES, AWOL?
AWOL.
THEN SHE LEFT.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK I'M GOING TO
SOUND VERY SMART BY USING THE
PHRASE DECOUPLING.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE I'M GOING TO
USE IN THE RIGHT WAY BUT I THINK
WE SHOULD DECOUPLE THE
IMPENETRABLE BORDER WITH
IMMIGRATION.
MAKE IT TO CLOSE EVERYTHING SO I
FOR HAVING A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
COME IN.
THEY ARE GREAT, WONDERFUL, MAKE
SURE THEY ARE VETTED AND STUFF
BUT WE SHOULD HAVE A WALL.
THE PROBLEM IS THE CRITICS HAVE
LUMPED THIS TOGETHER SO WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE WALL, THEY TRIED
TO GO YOU DON'T WANT THESE
PEOPLE TO COMMENT.
I AM FROM AN IMMIGRANT FAMILY.
WE ARE A NATION OF IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT.
WE WANT WHEN EVERYONE ELSE HAS
WHICH IS A PROCESS, A WALL.
NOT AWOL BUT THE WALL.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU SEE THE
CARAVAN.
PEOPLE WOULD SAY YOU'RE MAKING
UP THE CARAVAN BUT YOU ARE THERE
WITH THE VIDEO AND IT'S
HAPPENING AND WE KNOW IT'S GOING
TO TAKE PLACE THROUGHOUT THE
REST OF THE SUMMER.
I DON'T EVEN CARE.
FORGET THE MIDTERMS.
DO THEY REALIZE THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY DON'T.
>> Jessica: I DID A GOOGLE
SEARCH OF EVERYWHERE THIS IS
BEING COVERED TO SEE IF IT WAS
BEING COVERED FROM LEFT TO RIGHT
IN THE MOST INFORMATIVE ARTICLE
WAS IN THE GUARDIAN WHICH IS
ABOUT AS LEFT AS YOU CAN GET.
THEIR NUMBER WAS HIGHER THAN
OURS BUT IT'S UP TO 15,000
PEOPLE PART OF THE CARAVAN.
70% ARE WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
THAT WILL DEFINITELY CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC ON THE BORDER BECAUSE IT
HAD BEEN REPORTED THAT IT WAS
SINGLE MEN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN GIVEN PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT.
THIS PROBLEM AND WHAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE EXPRESSING IS THE
CONCERN TO WHY THEY ARE LEAVING
MEXICO WHICH IS THAT THERE ARE
NO JOBS FOR THEM IS EXACTLY THE
KIND OF PORTFOLIO THAT KAMALA
WAS CHARGED WITH.
THIS IS A ROOT CAUSE PROBLEM.
WE HAVE ECONOMIC DISASTER NOT
ONLY WERE THERE, HIM INITIALLY
BUT THAT IN MEXICO IT'S NOT AN
OKAY OPTION.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO WORK THIS
OUT WITH THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT
TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE ARE
COMING IN VETTED PROPERLY AND
ALSO THAT MEXICO GETS BACK ON
ITS FEET AND IS ABLE TO KEEP
PEOPLE UNDERGOING TO KEEP
MIGRATING NORTH.
I DON'T THINK THAT, HERE IS IS
LAZY.
I THINK SHE REALLY DIDN'T WANT
THIS JOB, THE SPECIFIC JOB AND
SHE LIKES THESE OTHER THINGS AND
I'M NOT SAYING IT MAKES IT OKAY
BUT SHE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
WOMEN'S EMPOWERMENT, SHE WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
>> Judge Jeanine: SO LET HER
DO IT.
>> Jessica: I'M NOT CALLING
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA LAZY.
I HEARD YOU DO IT TEN TIMES.
THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING.
>> Judge Jeanine: TWICE.
>> Jessica: THAT THIS ISN'T
WHAT SHE WANTS TO DO AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN LIFE WE ALL GET
JOBS THAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAVE THIS AS VP
AS WELL.
I'M SURE IT WASN'T HIS TOP
CHOICE.
HE WOULD HAVE RATHER DONE
GAY MARRIAGE.
HE ENDED UP WITH THE PORTFOLIO.
IT'S AN INTRACTABLE PROBLEM.
>> Dana: COULD PICK UP THE
PHONE AND CALL ANYBODY.
HIRE ANYBODY WANT TO GET ALL THE
HELP YOU WANT.
EVERYBODY GETS TO MAKE A CHOICE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON?